foreign
[Music]
our first kinjaz performance of all time
yeah we had this whole moment where they
literally took this and we're doing this
on stage people were cracking up funny
funny and then suddenly we turned into a
professional company I don't know how it
works
this is an Ohio based rap artist his
name uh is actually Joseph Edgar Foreman
owned by the surname Afroman uh he's
being sued by seven officers with the
Adams County Sheriff's Office for using
footage of their 2022 search on his home
to make and promote new music that's
tight oh wow the officers accused form
his use of their images and likeness as
a malicious act that tarnished their
reputation and humiliated them according
to a complaint I think it's [__] fun
it's funny here's a little does home
because of why because he got high
so he made a song called lemon pound
cake basically because like I guess his
mom like made some like sick ass 11
pound cake that was on the table and
like one of the fat [__] cops that
was like coming in stolen just kept on
like looking at him no
it on like security footage and stuff
whole 45 is one of my favorite Afroman
songs yeah
[Music]
well let's let's fast forward a little
bit
awesome labeled music he'll sue us
that's so funny he keeps looking at it
the Adams County Sheriff get down my
door
this is incredible
[Music]
okay
still got it bro dude and he has a
unique sound where you're like oh that's
Afroman yeah like he only sounds like
alphabet dude
wow I didn't realize that you wouldn't
be able to use that footage I guess
maybe not commercially the owner of that
footage yeah it's his own home security
stuff it's not like it's [__] footage
that he's somehow like maliciously took
from their body cams but the commercial
use is where it becomes illegal yeah
just I think the fact that there he's
clinical humiliating the cops you know
what I mean it's like look at this
[__] thing that's subjective yeah
he's a fat guy too so I'm like
he's like I mean Afroman's a fat guy so
what is he well they're gonna say like
oh he's fat shaming the fat man but the
average man's agreeing with the cop he's
like it is [__] delicious
yeah he's not even he's not he's not
taking sides no he's not like fat
shaming he's like you saw that didn't
you but the clip is just so objectively
funny he knocked down the door he didn't
post on IG he goes watch the physically
challenged officer take a double take on
that 11 pound cake he didn't know
whether to shoot me in my ass or cut him
a slice of that good old country lemon
pound cake I am mad at him I'm a big boy
too I take a double take on a lemon cake
my damn self LOL I'll give him a slice I
know everybody's trying to defund the
police I feel his pain but he doesn't
have to kick down my door and aim his
gun at me for a slice of lemon cake just
give me a call I'll throw some coffee
with it just let me keep my door this
economy is rough inflation is going up
on that lemon pound cake you can get
hurt for some 11 pound cake around here
these days lyrics no that's what he
wrote
himself it's good man isn't there very
few reasons why the cops would be
allowed to just kick your door down like
that well they probably had a warrant in
a raid do you think we get Afroman on
drinking news dude I think we get him on
Jacob that's what we should do we should
get all the our childhood like one
hitter quitters like The Jerky Boys yeah
dude get the tricky boys you got the
Jerky Boys the rule is a two knock rule
so if you go like this
after that cops can do anything
[__] donkey kick the back of your
door they just gotta get knocked to give
you two if they have a warrant give you
two chances police though wait two
knocks already yeah at least Hey listen
to a [__] mouth oh like the second
one two chances and then they get [__]
up yeah after that it's battering ram
anything what did you say coming and
then you know when you open the door
they kick it down and it [__] blows
you out
in his old house didn't even barely get
up from his chair he's got six thousand
[__] square feet to walk through it's
insane he's all like coming and it's too
late watching the [__] airport Hangar
he's like ah [__] you gotta power on
your golf cart to [__] drive over to
your front door do you guys like lemon
pound cake yes you do any pound cake I'm
in it tastes like it well to me it
tastes like or it smells like bathroom
pledge like pledge yeah I don't ever
gravitate towards 11 favored flavored
like Delicacies like that but when I eat
it and it's good I think it's [__]
bomb if they do the right amount of
lemon if they do bathroom stuff but it
needs to be the yeah it can't be too
tired nice little frosting and then just
a splash of that have you had lemon
lemon cello yeah
but that's like an alcoholic drink it's
[__] bombed and they serve those in
like Italy all the time after like you
eat a meal or something almost like
semi-licorice like yeah yeah it's
desserting you like a you're like a
lemon meringue oh yeah a pie almost all
cakes and pies they're my friends
I [__] with a key lime I don't like
lemon things it's key lime pie good
bro
it's hella Southern the lemon stuff you
gotta have with milk the non-lemon stuff
you have with some coffee or some tea I
do it all with coffee white people [__]
is like [__] casserole apple pie
have you seen that it's because
Americans are fat asses dude did you say
American cheese on apple pie yeah that's
like a thing that they do on like the
East Coast Americans yeah they put it on
top but why is it like a cheese crust is
that why no no they put a whole [__]
slime is this similar to like whoever
[__] discovered Hot Cheetos with
Philadelphia cream cheese that sounds
good see that sounds way more but is it
not melted is it just a slice of craft
single I think they don't really melt it
but they just throw it on Top Apple and
cheese just that's not fun because I I
was I was picturing like more portal
style you know they got the guava and
the cheese oh yeah and then or like a
cheesecake I don't see apple slices and
cheese I could [__] with but apple pie
with [__] American cheese on top get
the [__] out of it it's like I don't
know if it's like a Boston thing go back
to China dude
it's American cheese Chinese back to
China I will say though a slice of
American cheese on [__] like a shin
Ramen or like cup of noodles oh yeah
yeah when it's like melting at the top
and you just a little charm
it's not made for that Ginger bank is a
higher delicacy oh wow but you know what
I do want to try that I saw on Tick Tock
all right I saw some [__] they
took like uh one little cup of Shin Shin
ramens right and you make it like a
regular Shimmer I mean you eat the
noodle so it's just like the [__]
really a mystery then you take two eggs
you crack that [__] you put in that and
then you microwave it oh and then you
steam the egg you steam the egg with the
flavor of the shin Ramen and then it's
just a spicy soupy egg [__] souffle
whatever it's like a cindaboo something
yeah it just looks I haven't tried it
yet but [__] looks delicious dude
that sounds really good I'm more of a
Ramen guy with an egg in it on top you
know what I mean raw egg yummy that's
regular we're coming up with crafty
stuff right now or when you or when you
[__] fry an egg that's the best you
love that cast iron with like a bunch of
oil and it's like oh it's [__]
ripping hot it's good and you crack that
egg and it's a little little still yolky
on that that's nice but the bottom is
crunchy I like it I like that dude when
you I had kenja bang I got pepper right
I got Tabasco and I took that thing put
in the microwave and then I [__] it
like that and then I just had Pepper
with Tabasco I just looked up on my
fingers it was really good it's really
delicious
it was stupid
it's just him throwing the [__]
bottle coming off the car [__]
the extent that he goes to
we got like way a lot of time
[Laughter]
I'll do it in reverse
what was this article about it was an
Afroman lemon pound cake it's okay he
did the same thing about Filipino food
so you know what um
hot take right I don't get the munchies
anymore when I smoke stop smoking weed
well even when I do that
even when I do smoke weed I don't get
the munchies why do you think that is
yeah are you sure I'm a thousand percent
are you smoking a different kind of weed
for things all the time can I say
something though while you're high are
you eating anything nope so that's the
thing oh you have to get munchies you
have to eat something while you're high
and then the munchies ensues because
once you eat something it's just I want
to fade to the other yeah it's just like
oh man this is a little bit better when
I'm a little high I was always talking
about like like smoking weed and then
getting Munchies or just random urges
yeah like when you get high and then you
want because Afroman you know yeah and I
remember that used to be like a whole
sport to me like me my friends would
just like decide like all right we're
gonna do this we're gonna go to the
liquor store we're gonna [__] get
high in a parking lot and then we're
gonna buy the snacks so by the time we
get home we're [__] loaded and then
we're like eating the snacks while we
watch how high or something like that
yeah right and then like that's a dream
dude it would be planned out it's a good
day okay and then while you're like
smoking out in the the parking lot
you're just like all right when we go
into the market what are you gonna get
and you strategize and then you're
starting to get slowly High while you're
buying your snacks and you're just
excited because you're like what was it
what was the [__] you love the most
while you're [__] face or I would get
Taco Bell uh like I could get snacks but
like Taco Bell or like fruit roll-ups
would be good do the strawberry straws
oh yeah yeah yeah I just get a ton of
supreme tacos I'm boring very big Hot
Pockets kind of guy oh yeah The Bagel
Bites even Hot Pockets Bagel Bites with
some Flamin Hot Cheetos or a chicken
bake come on but I don't I don't crave
like that no more I don't and then I eat
food while I'm like high but I don't
it's not like how it used to be at all
you have to you and Hannah have to go to
a nice little restaurant and then you
guys just get baked a little bit before
and then you have a nice little adult
dining
meal oh man it's a good time amazing
good time we went to girl on the goat
girl on the goat is bong
it's [__] bomb I was a little high
and I was indulging in food and the I
guess they kept bringing out free plates
for us are they fans maybe your ass was
so hot you kept on ordering [__] no are
so with you was that was Yoshi so Darcy
yeah I was on a date with him I took him
out no but apparently they were like oh
we have extra so here wow and that's not
cheap either yeah and I was I think I
was really enjoying the food or
something and maybe they saw me like oh
that's good this food's High goes oh my
God
that's rice this is good I got sitting
there with a [__] napkin and [__]
yeah [__] you're like a white guy at
Panda Express he's like I love Chinese
food
oh honey we are coming here again one
time me and my buddies were thank you
we were eating a bucket of chicken we
had Popeyes right
and we're just [__] munching and in
this in the in the middle of eating uh a
fried chicken my [__] my buddy gets up
and he goes
he [__] slams The Chicken on the
[__]
and if we were just sitting here just
[__] what he's like my friend MO
we're just eating chicken and we started
like laughing so hard we almost choked
on chicken
you want to choke your chicken huh I bet
you did trick or treat that does sound
delicious though
[Music]